all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two
all-form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allform.com
pacman
so we're going to start today with this
incredible
interview that took place with the now
acquitted kyle rittenhouse on the fox
news channel's tucker carlson program
this was a much promoted interview and
it confirms every single one of our
suspicions about how kyle rittenhouse
would be treated after his acquittal
which is
they're making a hero out of him or at
least they're trying to and as you watch
these clips
consider the types of issues on which
this 18 year old kid
who killed two people when he was 17
is being not only asked to weigh in but
tucker's reactions a full-grown man
reacting as if this is who we should be
asking about such issues as
the fbi
prosecutorial misconduct
self-defense
and on and on and on so this is not only
the exact
predictable attempt to make a hero out
of kyle rittenhouse that we predicted
but it is actually making him to be even
more than that it's making him an
authority on self-defense it's making
him
so many more things so let's just jump
right into it tucker carlson introducing
this
and
saying
this is the type of person
you want
more of in your country if you can
imagine that
during the course of our long
conversation color right now struck us
as bright
decent sincere dutiful and hard working
exactly the kind of person you'd want
many more of in your country he's not
especially political he never wanted to
be the symbol of anything so even just
starting this
with this is just a great guy i'm tucker
and you trust me and i tell you all the
time what we need in this country
and we need more kyle written houses
that's how they set the stage and then
immediately
you have kyle rittenhouse saying
this was about self-defense this trial
was about self-defense big picture which
the right loves
he's their hero
it wasn't kyle ridden house on trial in
wisconsin it was the right to
self-defense on trial
and if i was convicted
no one would be able
no one would ever be privileged to
defend their life against attackers
now what kyle rittenhouse wants you to
believe
and what others want you to believe
is that if in this particular case there
had been a conviction
and again it could have been a
conviction just on one of the counts it
could have been well
with the rosenbaum killing it wasn't
self-defense
but maybe with anthony huber it was
which i my instinct was if there was
going to be any guilty verdict that
would have been written house and it
would have been rosenbaum and not huber
but that's neither here nor there he
wants you to believe any any guilty
verdict here would mean people can't
defend themselves anymore
however that's an extremely myopic view
of the facts which include his choice to
go there and his choice to go to provide
medical help supposedly but with a gun
and on and on this is not about
adjudicating the trial but it's the idea
that what does this 18 year old know
about self-defense he got himself into
an insane situation got away with
killing two people under the guise of
self-defense but now we're going to him
for advice about self-defense and what
this means it's crazy
um of course at a certain point you've
got to bring up god and he believes he
had god on his side you know you just
got acquitted yeah i mean like two days
ago so that was the first thing i
noticed that you seem very calm
you don't seem like someone who's just
been through uh
you know had his mind blown
yeah on the inside i'm freaking out but
the best thing you do you freak out
everybody else freaks out it's like a
chain reaction yes so the best thing i
can do is stay calm
do you feel like you've been watched
over
i believe god's been on my side in the
beginning yeah there you go i mean what
what what an amazing perspective that
tucker is eliciting here right uh and
the entire interview was essentially
like this and if you what's very
interesting is
it really illuminates the difference
between a propaganda interview and a
real interview
because now we're going to look at an
example of when rittenhouse is allowed
to get away
with
something with tucker that he never
would have been able to get away with in
court he says you know after i did shoot
joseph rosenbaum
i was going to render first aid when in
the trial
through cross-examination it was clear
that that that was not the case
he shot
you decide at that point
listen miss remembering you're you want
to turn yourself into the police yes
um
after i shoot mr rosenbaum
um
he tried to grab my gun i was running
away there was a gun shot behind me
after i shoot him i run around the car
because i was gonna go render first aid
to him even this i mean this this story
is not the story that came out in the
trial
rosenbaum grabbed my gun
in order to take it from kyle
rittenhouse that's a detail that was
left unclear from the case i'm not
saying was or wasn't self-defense again
i as i said from the beginning i think
the facts lend themselves to a
reasonable doubt that this was
self-defense as kyle rittenhouse saw it
but this story he tried to grab my gun
and i still ran around the car to try to
give him first aid after the first shot
that's not really what the video appears
to show but in a propaganda interview
you're allowed to get away with it i
wasn't able to because then
there was a mob forming and
calling for my execution to get him and
kill him and of course what's in between
that that kyle rittenhouse doesn't
mention are the three further shots to
rosenbaum
after rosenbaum was already seemingly
disabled so it's not about relitigating
the case it's about understanding that
this is a propaganda interview where
he's allowed to give any version of
events even versions of events not
backed up by the exhibits presented in
the trial uh and and that conflict with
with what came out in the trial okay um
let's look at another clip here
this case has nothing to do with race um
it never had anything to do with race it
had to do with the right to self-defense
right
um i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody
so
once again this is another one of those
examples of
18 year old kyle rittenhouse on
prosecutorial misconduct they're making
him an authority they're making him a
hero they're making him a poster child
when
just because you were accused of a crime
doesn't mean you know anything about
supposed prosecutorial misconduct and he
knows that now oh and people are
commenting oh he supports blm okay maybe
we have no idea what that means maybe he
does i'm not denying that he does it
might just mean he supports blm insofar
as they have a right to be heard at
protests
it could mean it doesn't really matter
here but he's learning the talking
points and in this next clip you're
going to see him do the fbi stuff which
is remember among the right now you have
to criticize the fbi
and he says
i don't know if they're going to be able
to keep me safe you know how the fbi
works which it would this this is
classic
red meat to those who know what to
listen for it to look at the facts of
what happened
do do you feel the threats
i do i see some of the threats some of
the things people say it's absolutely
sickening
has do are you confident that the
government will protect you from these
threats because that's of course the
government's job
i hope so but we all know how the fbi
works
yeah
i mean
looking back
it's been
you know okay
um so he he's on but he knows the
talking points he knows it we got to be
very skeptical and critical of the fbi
that's something that grew significantly
under trump
um and that has become sort of a
standard calling card now of right-wing
media so he's he's got that one he
learned that one for sure the topic of
joe biden came up and um kyle
rittenhouse even uh given the
opportunity to send a message directly
to president joe biden besides like my
case
what did you make of the president
united states calling you a white
supremacist
mr president if i could say one thing to
you i would urge you to go back and
watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement
that's not a small thing to be called
that
no it's
it's actual malice defaming my character
for him to say something like that
defaming defamation we're gonna come
back to that because that actually comes
up again
now in the midst of this
you might remember that all sorts of
shady characters got wrapped up with
kyle rittenhouse early on one of them is
lynn wood this
sort of trump-affiliated wacky attorney
who's made all sorts of insane claims
about
uh kovid as well as about the 2020
elections and this is this is sort of a
departure from what we've been talking
about
um
he uh kyle rittenhouse talks about how
he believes he was taken advantage of by
some of these lawyers who were raising
money for themselves and he was kept in
jail and it's actually this is this is
just a crazy aspect to this
how long were you there i was in jail
for 87 days and
this goes as follows in with lynn wood
who
lynnwood
was raising money on my behalf and he
held me in jail for 87 days
disrespecting my wishes put me on media
interviews which i should never have
done when she said oh you're gonna go
talk to the washington post which was
not a good idea along with john pierce
they said i was safer in jail instead of
at home with my family and then after
i'm bill your lawyer said that my lawyer
said that john pierce and lynn wood
87 days is a long time to be in jail
it was
it was very long i lost a lot of weight
in there i i since then gained it back
i know the feeling yeah
so this is crazy this is a propaganda
interview but it also shows you that
um
these sort of predatory
figures like lynn wood they're
everywhere and there's no opportunity
that they won't take advantage of uh and
here written house talks about
how he was treated in jail now there's
two there's two sides to this part let's
listen split
um
but i didn't have running water
seriously i had a phone also but i did
not have running water so i didn't
shower until november 20th
from october 31st to november 20th i did
not take a shower that's disgusting i it
very um i smelled terrible i felt sick i
lost weight my health was degrading yeah
so what's interesting about this one is
this has happened in the context of the
january 6 riots as well
where
you know we by we i mean we on the left
have been sounding the alarm about jail
and prison conditions pre-trial
detention etc for more than a decade on
this program
and the right
has not cared about it until
it affects them
and so now you've heard everybody from
marjory taylor green to who knows who on
the right complain about the alleged
conditions conditions in which the
alleged january 6th trump rioters have
been held and now
jail conditions all of a sudden are a
big deal to them and similarly now all
of a sudden with the written house stuff
that issue is now they care about that
issue now it's actually an important
issue
but it's again
the brazen nature
by which they only care about it when it
affects them
there have been questions is kyle
rittenhouse going to sue media outlets
for things they said about him various
legal opinions about whether that would
go anywhere but kyle written house sort
of using coded language to say yeah we
may do that um and they would like to
see you
you know help make this better by
holding some of these liars to account
do you plan to do that i have really
good lawyers who are taking care of that
right now um
so
i'm hoping one day there will be some
there would be accountability for their
actions that they did okay so you're
you're intent on not you're not going to
let that go
uh like i said
so
suggesting there that they there may
well be defamation suits coming and
where those will go we have absolutely
no idea but it's looking like this is
going to be a very litigious year or two
for kyle rittenhouse and then lastly uh
kyle rittenhouse the the lionization and
the heroism continues with kyle um
talking about what kind of a career he
wants to pursue what do you think your
life's gonna be like after this
i'm hoping i can live a quiet
stress-free life
and not and be free of any intimidation
or harassment and just go on with my
life as a normal 18 year old kid
attending college so you're gonna go to
college i am in college i'm a student at
arizona state university now
in the trial it
it seems like that was not true unless
something has changed but that's really
neither here nor there well i mean are
you going to go to campus and
i i think i am i want to um it's a lot
of things we have to look into so i
don't know for sure yet
but i i do intend on going in campus and
pursuing a career in nursing
i may change it i've been looking into
law i may want to become a lawyer i
haven't completely decided yet
but i've been looking i i want to be a
nurse so i've been doing the
prerequisites for how nice right so
exactly as predicted this is the new
hero this is the new hero and of course
you can judge for yourselves based on
your values
uh and how you see the world whether you
think that he's worthy of being
designated this hero but weighing in on
everything from prosecutorial misconduct
to the trustworthiness of the fbi
on the basis of the fact that he killed
two people and was acquitted for it um
exactly as we predicted on december 14th
we will be doing our next david pakman
show viewer town hall it will be on the
pacman live youtube channel
make sure you're subscribed to that
channel at youtube.com pacman live we're
going to take a quick break and be back
right after this
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video
so we've been talking about the
um
authoritarian slide of the united states
over the last many years which goes
beyond donald trump it accelerated under
donald trump but it actually goes beyond
donald trump
and now for the first time ever the
united states has actually been listed
as a backsliding democracy this has
never happened before the guardian has a
very interesting article about it us
added to list of backsliding democracies
for the first time
visible deterioration in u.s civil
liberties began in at least 2019 says
international think tank this is the
international idea think tank
globally more than one in four people
live in a backsliding democracy
a proportion that rises to more than two
and three when you include authoritarian
or hybrid regimes according to the
stockholm based international institute
for democracy and electoral assistance
this year we coded the united states as
backsliding for the first time
but our data suggests the backsliding
episode began at least in 2019.
the united states is a high-performing
democracy and even improved its
performance in indicators of impartial
administration corruption and
predictable enforcement in 2020 however
the declines in civil liberties and
checks on government indicate that there
are serious problems with the
fundamentals of democracy
a historic turning point came in 2021
when former president trump questioned
the legitimacy of the 2020 election
results hudson pointed to a decline in
the quality of freedom of association
and assembly during the summer of
protests in 2020 after the police
killing of george floyd international
idea based its assessments on 50 years
of democratic indicators in 160
countries there are three categories for
democracies uh including those that are
backsliding hybrid governments and
authoritarian regimes another word for a
backsliding democracy is creeping
authoritarianism
or autocratization democratic decay
de-democratization
a gradual decline in the quality of
democracy the opposite of
democratization if unchecked
democratic backsliding results in the
state losing its democratic qualities
becoming an autocracy or an
authoritarian regime now there's another
aspect to this the other aspect to this
is
that when you talk about
authoritarianism
and you talk about people like donald
trump
it is not just about what they would
like to see implemented there's this
other aspect we've talked about which
princeton has studied which is
whose
goals
are more likely to be made policy and in
that sense the us hasn't really been a
representative democracy for a long time
wherein the the policy goals
of the rich and of big corporations are
far more likely to be made law than
those of the average person i mean you
know you look at things like is the
estate tax
the estate tax in which an individual
has an 11 million dollar exemption and a
couple has 22 million dollars in exempt
money that they can pass to heirs
tax-exempt money
that benefits a very small portion of
people
and yet it has been a mainstay in some
form or another to some degree or
another for a long time and we talk
about so many other rules that benefit
large corporations that that's been a
concern for a long time and then now in
addition you have this now one one last
thing i do want to mention about this
there's another aspect to this
which is
there is the belief from some on the
right
that aside from freedom rankings and all
these different things
that there are great things in the u.s
like for example the u.s is just the
best place to be doing business to have
a business to be an entrepreneur that's
also not true and it's important when we
talk about pros and cons every place has
pros and cons and when we look at
something like oh no now the us is
officially a backsliding democracy when
they say yeah but it's like the best
place to do business that's also not
true and as one example if you look at
the open for business rankings and you
actually look at what what are the
places you see that it's switzerland
number one panama number two canada
number three canada denmark number four
sweden places that the right often likes
to say are
nanny state pseudo socialist places rank
higher
for business environment than the united
states new zealand
norway ireland many
originally us-based businesses uh moving
operations or partially moving
operations to ireland you have finland
netherlands malaysia australia belgium
it's a very very long list
before you ultimately get to the united
states which i can't even find at this
point because it is quite far down the
list latvia croatia and of course this
has to do with everything from
regulation to amount of paperwork and
the united states ranking 45th in the
open for business rankings exactly the
same as 2020. so the important thing
here is when they say well you might
point out this part that's not so good
but this other one is really good
actually go and look it up because it's
not always the case and of course if you
believe in openness democracy
um
anti-authoritarianism as i do
you don't want to see the u.s listed as
a backsliding democracy for the first
time but alas that's where we are
and this goes beyond just who's
president this has this has a lot to do
with many different aspects including
surveillance including corruption
including so many different things
not going in the right direction let's
take a quick break and we'll be right
back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
making his uh triumphant return today
defiant and triumphant i would say uh to
the david pakman show is andrew yang
entrepreneur
turned politician author of the new book
forward notes on the future of our
democracy which i was uh glad glad to
take a look at a couple weeks ago when
you sent it to me um former democratic
presidential primary candidate former
new york city mayoral candidate i mean
there's just so much to talk about but
uh it's great having you back on
thanks david it's great to be here it's
been so long been far too long it has so
you know you and i we have many things
in common and many things not in common
one of the things we have in common is
we we are pragmatists we both run for
president david is that what happened i
can't i i'm a naturalized citizen so i
cannot do it that is something i unless
the law changes i will never be able to
do sadly but
but in our pragmatism
i think we both prioritize solving
problems and that comes through in the
book it came through in your
presidential campaign etc to solve
problems we've got to figure out what
created the problem so to what do you
attribute the current division that
exists politically in the united states
in a word david incentives uh but one of
the things i found
in researching and writing my book was
that this is not normal we are not in
normal times if you rewind a number of
decade well if you go way back to the
founding of the country uh then they're
not fans of political parties the
republican party comes about in the wake
of the civil war starts out as the
northern anti-slavery party but the two
parties
despite trading power back and forth for
about a hundred years were kind of
indistinguishable ideologically
until the 1960s reorganizes things
somewhat with the civil rights movement
and then you have the end of the
fairness doctrine the beginning of cable
tv in the 90s and so the two parties
have started diverging ideologically and
politically
really over the last 30 40 years or so
and that's given rise to the urban rural
divide the educated less educated divide
but all the political incentives now are
around the extremes because
83 plus of the congressional races are
decided in the primary so in each party
in order to get reelected you just want
to not get primaried which means you're
going to be trying to keep people off
your back in the extreme flank of your
party see this very clearly with the
republicans or if someone says a bad
word about trump they then get attacked
and cast out so you have these political
incentives around the extremes and then
you have media incentives compounding
those extremes by separating us into
ideological armed camps at this point
and then you have social media on top of
it so this is why we feel like we're
careening towards political violence and
worse and i just want to commend folks
like you because i do see independent
media as the antidote like you all
aren't as ideological or
inflammatory in many cases of course
there are people that are like that but
not you david
so
so the the the polarization we're
feeling is now a very predictable result
of all of the political and media
incentives that are driving the system
okay i i mostly i you know small issues
i could take with that but for our
discussion today
basically agree with with the assessment
so we then get to
the forward movement the forward party
bridging this gap finding something that
maybe can cross the traditional party
lines that more people can agree with
um first question is what is it that you
think would be appealing to people from
these two sometimes ideological extremes
sometimes just ideological differences
well i would say that polarization is a
bad thing for everyone let's say you're
on the left and you'd like to get
something done on climate change and you
look up and you're like why can we not
get anything done on climate change a
republican senator said something to me
that really hit home she said
andrew we
get rewarded more for keeping an issue
around than resolving it
and the example i've been using is marco
rubio suggesting immigration reform and
then he gets shipped by the republican
party he's like never mind never mind
nothing to see so if you are on the left
and you're like why can't we do things
that 60 70 75 of us want
then you'd want to try and reform this
system to become more rational and more
responsive to the desire of the majority
of us and you can go down the list on
issues you go immigration and go climate
change let's take climate change i mean
so i think this is where we might have
our first disagreement completely agree
with you that the senate the system by
explicitly and implicitly with things
like the term limits that we have almost
always having to be campaigning for your
next election all these different things
don't prioritize solutions to long-term
problems like climate change i agree
with everything you've said and yet
part of climate change is
a huge portion of one side
doesn't believe it's real or if they do
they don't believe humans are a factor
so this is where i get to your analysis
is great
i don't think it accounts for it's more
than that when one side simply won't
accept the science how do you get those
people to buy in
all right so let's play this out yeah
um what proportion of americans don't
believe that climate change is real or
caused by humans
the last i've seen it's uh oh we i wish
i had the data in front of me i think
it's about
half or 60 percent of republicans don't
believe it's caused by humans and maybe
25 33 something like that don't believe
it's even happening at all
yeah so that lines up with what what i
thought the numbers were roughly um so
let's imagine that you have
like gross numbers 35 percent of
americans who either don't think climate
change is caused by humans or it's not a
big deal or whatever it is and that that
percentage is declining happily or
unhappily because it's becoming so
apparent apparent around us yeah so
right now you have a republican party
that is motivated by that
uh
you know let's call it for argument's
sake um
roughly half of the republican party or
a bit more does not think climate change
is something we should do anything about
sure
the problem is that that relative
minority
ends up controlling the agenda for
half of the country and then can stall
any real move uh to change it yes
so let's say hypothetically instead of
having two parties we had four parties
or five parties and you had progressive
democrats moderate democrats
foreignists
moderate republicans uh and conservative
republicans and the conservatives would
be like hey climate change bunk let's
not do a thing but then you you'd have
four
like the four other groups look up and
say
um
we should do something about it so what
you're seeing here is is not quite
minority rule but it's minority
uh
veto or it's minority keeping anything
from happening and so this is the system
as it currently
is made up uh so
the thing that i want people to come to
grips with is that politics right now is
completely tribal
and you can be very very angry at what
another tribe says or feels but the
problem right now is that we only have
two tribes and it doesn't take much to
gum up the works which is why we're all
losing our minds getting more polarized
and frustrated yeah and so this this
gets us to really a discussion of of
third parties and i'm curious
i have a view as to why third parties
have not become uh um more significant
at the national level i'm curious what
what your view is my view is it's
essentially two things it's not for lack
of want of more options
it's not for uh
lack of political diversity
it's not because of the desire for more
political diversity in the major parties
people want that it's two things one
that the the side whose third party does
best ultimately risks being a spoiler
and people who say i'd like a third this
is the age-old green party thing i mean
this is not new right oh i like this it
probably gets the people i really don't
want in power if it goes well and number
two connected to that how politics is is
financed in the united states as well
those are for me the two main reasons
why what do you see
in a word incentives
so so if you
uh if you
decide to break from the two major
parties all of a sudden you don't have
uh capital structure you don't have
votes you don't have media yep and so
you're in the wilderness now i i do want
to return to the you're gonna mess it up
for whatever team you're closer to
this is one reason why the first big
move the forward party is making is to
push for ranked choice voting combined
with open primaries because if you had
rank choice voting in an election you
could vote green one democrat two
republican three and then no one needs
to worry about it um the the problem
right now is that the duopoly wants to
stifle any competition and it uses fear
it's like uh if i had a buck for every
time someone said oh you're gonna mess
it up for the democrats even though the
numbers do not make it clear that that's
exactly what i'd be doing and i have
said absolutely nothing about uh you
know a national race like i'm trying to
get things done at the local level for
for 22. but if you were to shift to rank
choice voting then the spoiler effect
disappears which is exactly why we need
it and also exactly why the duopoly
doesn't want to talk about it because to
your point at this point a majority of
americans want to move on from the
duopoly we know it's not working but we
just keep being told we can't have it
because of this archaic voting system
that we could change if enough of us got
together to say look let's just do
everything by ranked choice voting no
more spoiler effect
but the parties don't want that because
the parties know that we actually don't
like them very much
and that the only reason we're choosing
a is because they're trying to scare us
about b
so the question then becomes how do you
i mean this is sort of like when an
elected official says
uh as soon as i get in i'm gonna do
uh voting you know election reform and
campaign finance performance like hold
on a second you're gonna come to power
under the system we have and then change
the system that worked to get you in
power it to go to incentives it doesn't
seem like you'll be super incentivized
to do that the same question sort of
applies here if we need to make the
changes you're talking about to campaign
finance and how votes are counted first
past the post in order to make the third
party more reasonable more viable
how are we going to make those changes
uh so the forward party has two
major
endeavors uh in 2022. okay number one is
that and it turns out because the
political parties are made up
that we could actually get together and
change to an open primary ranked choice
voting at the state level yes in 24
states around the country if just not
enough of us got together and for people
who think like oh this will never happen
it happened last year in one state
alaska 2020 changed from party primaries
to open primaries and ranked choice
voting and you immediately saw the
result when senator lisa murkowski of
alaska voted to impeach donald trump the
only republican senator to do so who's
up for re-election in 2022.
her approval rating among alaskan
republicans is now six percent so it is
genuinely politically suicidal for a
republican to go against trump but she
can skip the party primary it doesn't
exist anymore you have an open primary
so she can take her case the entire
alaskan public
and then say look like i'm an
independent person bring me back so if
we make the same change that alaska made
in three four five states around the
country in 2022 imagine six eight ten
senators some of them republican who are
then free of the thrall of their party
free to do what they think is right
maybe they'll even support
uh protecting secretaries of state from
election interference you know like so
this is something we can do if we had
enough americans get together and do
what they did in alaska so that's step
one which we don't have to wait for
anyone to do we can do it right now
they're not to us so that's what the
forward party is about trying to gather
that movement
the second thing is we can support
candidates who are
fighting on principle
as democrats independents or republicans
and i'm just going to call out someone
who who i doubt people in your program
talk much about
there is a west virginia congressman
named david mckinley who co-sponsored a
cash relief bill that i lobbied for
and voted
yes on infrastructure he's one of the 13
republicans to do so he's now facing a
fight with a trumper
and who the heck is going to help david
mckinley like the democrats would be
like oh he's a republican so screw it uh
you know but i'm going to suggest that a
lot of americans should be getting
behind david mckinley uh and some other
reasonable republicans who are
endangered species because they're
taking flack for doing the right thing
um you meant so that's interesting so
you mentioned a republican
is there a prominent democrat right now
that people in my audience might know
that you think is particularly suited
and tailored for the the milieu
of the forward party as you describe it
i believe elizabeth warren came out as
pro-rank choice voting um when it was up
on the ballot in massachusetts last year
so anyone who's for running choice
voting i'm excited about and there are a
number of uh prominent democrats and
uh democracy reformers who have taken
that stance i think corey might have
done so as well
i'm i'm really curious about the
coalition that you envisioned to some
degree you know when i told my audience
that you were going to be on the most
frequent question i got in different
iterations was
who exactly that currently considers
themselves to be on the right
does andrew yang imagine bringing into
the forward party and to kind of
make it a little more specific you know
we would imagine that there's lots of
progressive democrats more centrist
democrats even some folks who really
consider themselves centrist maybe in
the kind of line of even like a john
mccain who like the idea of some of the
reforms you're talking about and that
all kind of makes sense to me
when i think about people who believe
donald trump won the election
vaccines
the covet vaccine magnetizes you causes
autism whatever the case may be
etc right you know the package of ideas
that i'm talking about one are are those
people that would even conceivably say
this forward party idea that andrew yang
proposes in a coalition with the left
makes sense and number two are these
even people that you want as part of
your coalition
first let me say i want everyone as part
of the coalition you know if you can
vote we can disagree on a lot of things
uh it's all to the good if we agree on
the fact that this
uh
duopoly's
working is designed to turn us against
each other and sync us so that that's
one of the principles of the ford party
is that look i can disagree with you on
a lot of stuff but if we can make common
cause on this then we can go back to
disagreeing when the democracy is
actually set up to succeed when they're
you know
so let me i mean let me ask so even i
mean to to make it really specific
if people on the right say the
republican party is too centrist i'm an
extreme white supremacist or something
like that but i think we need to get you
know we need single transferable vote or
whatever and campaign you you you still
welcome that because you're on the same
page on that one issue
yeah if they're going to help us
transition to a more effective democracy
um but you know i don't need to know
what their stance is on things that i
disagree with people have a sense of
where i'm coming from okay but right now
i believe that there is
an existential threat to the country um
as a result of the greatest design flaw
in the history of the world uh that is
and if if you will help us resolve that
design flaw then we can have a
discussion about anything else under the
sun at a time when the democracy
actually will stand the test of time
when we transition to a multi-party
system where you can't make any
autocratic or authoritarian decisions
you have to somehow get two or three
other parties on board okay all right
fair so on the question of is everyone
literally welcome the answer is yes
that's that's fine that's legitimate so
so you've that that's clear uh now in
terms of to whom
that currently typically votes for
republicans would this appeal
where are you on that
there are all sorts of folks who are
displeased with trump there's a person
online who said the other day it's like
look i voted for trump uh twice and i
don't even want him back
like there are voters out there uh who
are concerned about the country
uh and uh i've i've been heartened by
the fact that i've gotten a lot of
incoming
uh expressions of support from um
military veterans
uh members of law enforcement or former
law enforcement who despair about the
state of the country they see where it's
going to and they say this is what i've
been waiting for
there's an independent community
that right now is politically homeless
uh that they're very numerous there are
44 of americans consider themselves
independents
uh and i would say that
we're seeing a lot of them come in like
one of the things i'm going to suggest
first if you look at the appetite for a
third party it's higher among both
republicans and independents than
democrats so if you imagine who's going
to draw third-party energy like if or
where it's going to come from it like by
the numbers it's likely to come from
those groups
and imagining that every republican or
former republican or independent uh is
excited about trump is just not right
you know but but saying that that group
is also
open to democrats is also not right i
have encountered so many americans who
just shut down when you have a d next
your name sure which i found unfortunate
but the thing i want to suggest to
people is that again all politics is
tribal at this point um and so what we
need to do is we need to have more
tribes emerge that we have a chance if
we stick to two tribes we're done
last thing i want to ask you about and
we're shifting gears a little bit but
because your background in technology
i'm very curious as to your insights
particularly as someone who who used
social media really effectively in the
democratic primary run that you made
all the talk now about the so-called
regulation of social media
one interesting um artifact of this has
been
the rapidity with which those who have
for a long time claimed businesses
should be able to do whatever they want
as long as it's not illegal are now
demanding
that social media companies be forced to
allow messages that violate their terms
of service to be up that's a hypocrisy
we could talk about but i don't want to
focus on that necessarily today what i'm
curious about from your perspective is
what should be the regulatory
infrastructure as to the social networks
particularly from this point of view of
political bias that don jr
whoever else are regularly tweeting
about and sort of saying we are the
victims here what what would you like to
see
uh i think our government needs to
modernize its approach to social media
and technology in general right now it's
behind the curve it's laughable or
embarrassing um this is also an
outgrowth of our geritocracy david i
mean that the reality is that our
congressional leaders are in their 70s
or 80s if it is biden versus trump in 24
which it looks like it's going in that
direction their combined age will be 158
yeah so then asking our government to
understand what's going on in social
media is at least right now a bridge too
far and like that has to change
if i were in charge
i would be getting into the guts of
these social media companies
uh setting what jonathan hype suggested
as like a filter where you
end up being able to just like ignore
people who are
customarily aggressive obnoxious i mean
you can watch it if you want or get
those messages if you want but you
actually set up a way to reward people
who tend to be more balanced and normal
in their conversation okay because right
now the the energy in social media
rewards the more
aggressive or sensationalistic you're
self-accepted again you just like keep
it uh keep it even keeled and yet
everyone loves you well you should see
the emails i get but so it sounds like
you're not saying you would be in favor
of the government going to youtube and
saying you've got to leave up
anti-vaccine content
well there are certain things that you'd
have to say are in the public good
uh that
you know and there's disinformation and
there's this information that can be uh
uh
destructive in a way that you know like
if you are
a functioning society you do not want to
say like every idea is the same
including ideas that by the way in this
case could lead people to lose their
lives
so so in other words
you want to make it easier to control
one's experience on these platforms but
not take the approach that some on the
right are saying which is
these comp these platforms should be
forced to allow content that violates
their terms of service again as long as
it's not illegal on the basis of
discrimination on
on race or sex or this type of thing
well i'm going to echo what some of the
social media ceos themselves say which
is like why are we in position to make
this decision
and the reason they're making that
decision is because the government is
absent um one of the social media ceo
said look we should get together
tech
government media non-profits and set
rules the road so it's not just us doing
the content moderation decision then you
yelling at us about it because wherever
they draw the line they're going to get
yelled at
you know i happen to think the
conservatives are off base in terms of
saying like oh you know you're sludging
conservative content it's like
conservative content actually performs
great on a lot of these platforms
um and if there's anything we should be
concerned about it's the deteriorating
mental health of our young people
teenage girls in particular so if you're
a conservative like get mad about that
in my mind
like isn't that a bigger issue than the
fact that you know anyway and i guess
then the question would become if
facebook knew that was going on and was
hiding it for a period of time are they
really good faith players to be involved
in figuring out the regulation which
which is sort of a second order question
well they can be at the table but we
should stop pretending that companies
are going to do anything other than
what's going to maximize their financial
returns which is exactly what you'd
expect them to do so
like so if you have that expectation and
then you go in and say hey guess what
we're going to do things that are going
to make your financial returns lower uh
and tough luck you know and and so one
thing i suggested as like a random thing
it's like maybe instagram should turn
off for teenagers between midnight and 7
a.m like you know maybe just looking at
pictures of your high school classmates
is something we don't want you to do in
the middle of the night you know like
you know it's
like
just like a random thought um and and so
you can see that kind of like would
facebook be excited about that of course
not they'd be like oh we make money then
we make money all the time
uh the book is forward notes on the
future of our democracy i really
appreciate uh reading the book and uh
we've been speaking with the book's
author andrew yang always great having
you on and i really appreciate your time
thank you david great to be back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show all right we teased that this might
happen and it's happening beto o'rourke
former democratic presidential candidate
uh is running for governor in texas
against republican incumbent greg abbott
i think number one this is great this is
exciting it would be fantastic to remove
greg abbott greg abbott's approval
ratings have been sinking and sinking
and sinking in the context of his total
humiliating farcical mishandling of
kovid
but can beto o'rourke actually win in
texas particularly given some of the
things he said about guns in the past i
hope the answer is yes but i don't know
beto o'rourke held the gubernatorial
campaign kickoff in dallas announced his
candidacy monday three republicans are
also running for the office
now
the um rally speech that he gave
was good you know he's he's a good
speaker
all
considering he's uh excites people to
some degree let's listen to a little bit
of it
greg abbott chose not to expand medicaid
would not take yes for an answer from
the federal government when they offered
to pay
95 cents on the dollar for expanded
health care in texas we are the least
insured state in the country by a texas
mile
there are more who cannot see a doctor
or fill a prescription or take their
child to a therapist than in any other
state in the union in this community we
still see people dying
of diabetes a hundred years after
insulin was developed which cost pennies
to distribute still some people in
dallas cannot afford to buy it and are
dying of it
the common flu
curable cancers
these things are taking our moms our
dads our grandparents so these are great
talking points but are they the right
talking points for texas i don't know
the answer as 538 has written about
texas voters have soured on greg abbott
but that doesn't mean they'll vote for
beto o'rourke
abbott is not as popular as he once was
his disapproval has now climbed close to
50 his approval is below 45
but the question that 538 asks
is
what about voters in looking at abbott
versus beto or rorke and it looks okay
for beto o'rourke but he has similar
dislike numbers to greg abbott and he's
not even he's only now starting to run
for something he's not the incumbent
governor that's potentially a red flag
um the
point in favor of greg abbott quite
frankly is this horrible abortion law
that's been passed in texas i'm sorry
the point in favor of better or work
against greg abbott is the abortion law
that's been passed in texas which we've
discussed that's certainly something
that could mobilize voters
but i have real concerns because i
imagine that this clip is going to be
played on repeat this was when beto
o'rourked during the democrat one of the
democratic presidential debates was
asked about firearms and this is
my advice is always just don't even talk
about firearms in campaigns because it
really just mobilizes republicans to
vote against you but remember this
are you proposing taking away their guns
and how would this work
i am if it's a weapon that was designed
to kill people
on a battlefield
right
so that did well with a democratic crowd
but as i've said before that can really
crush you
in texas so
i'm excited about this it would be
amazing to remove an incumbent
republican governor in texas and replace
him with a democratic challenger we're
going to be following this race we're
going to be talking about it a lot
helping and in hoping to
inspire people to get mobilized there
i just don't know if bet or work is
actually the right candidate and i'm not
the only one who has this concern so we
are going to continue following that
very closely
the legal problems for conspiracy
theorist alex jones and for former trump
associate roger stone
uh continue
and uh you might remember that on the
one hand roger stone
um was convicted and subsequently
pardoned
but he had has had his fair share of
legal trouble alex jones is in the
middle of multiple lawsuits including
some related to his conspiracy theories
and false claims of a false flag
in the context of the sandy hook
shooting back in 2012
and they both now have even more legal
troubles alex jones and roger stone have
been subpoenaed by the house panel
investigating the january 6th riots
the panel said it subpoenaed trump
spokesman taylor budowicz republican
political operative roger stone and
conspiracy monger alex jones as well as
two others in a report by cnbc
the house panel says the new recipients
who have been asked for testimony and
documents are believed to have knowledge
of the plans and funding for the rallies
on january 6th now we're going to see
whether they actually
uh respond to these subpoenas or whether
they will end up being held in contempt
but these are clearly key figures and
there's a few different things to think
about alex
steve bannon has also now
uh been indicted for his ignoring of a
subpoena from this committee so a few
different things number one
it really seems like alex jones is an
important figure in the january six
trump riots the day before the riots
there's a video that was posted to his
website infowars.com
which shows him telling a crowd in
freedom plaza in washington dc
we have only begun to resist the
globalists or globalish as he says
we have only begun to fight against
tyranny
they have tried to steal this election
in front of everyone i don't know how
this is all going to end he said but if
they want to fight
they better believe they've got one that
was the night before the january sixth
riots
this guy seems to be up to his eyeballs
involved in this thing and he has now
been subpoenaed roger stone has now been
subpoenaed trump spokesman taylor buddha
which has been subpoenaed and of course
stephen bannon ignored his subpoena and
has now been indicted for that will we
ever really learn the full scope of the
planning that pr the pre-planning that
went on i don't know if we will i really
don't
uh but it's pretty clear that these guys
are up to their eyeballs in this stuff
and the january 6 committee should keep
going and going and going there may not
be political consequences in fact
unfortunately i think there probably
will not be
um the
elected officials
who were involved
are mostly in safe red districts in safe
red states or not even up for
re-election when it comes to senators in
the immediate future
and they will most likely all get
reelected and there probably won't be
legal consequences for them
but when it comes to people like alex
jones whoever they can get
they should pursue if that's where the
evidence points and that is absolutely
where the evidence is pointing right now
so continued legal trouble for alex
jones and others and we'll see what
comes of it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p you can call
absolutely anytime you want
yesterday on the show i sort of
offhandedly made an analogy
uh when it comes to asymmetric risk and
a mathematical term called expected
value and i talked about a ten-sided die
and i incorrectly said the expected
value would be five i got a number of
polite voicemails and emails saying
david you got that wrong here is one of
them
david sir i believe you made a mistake
in your discussion of expected value on
the show yes if you roll a ten sided die
and earn the amount of money that shows
up on the die such as one dollar for a
one two dollar for two etcetera as you
discussed your expected value is
actually five dollars and fifty cents
not just five dollars yes just try it
add up all the numbers from one to ten
and divide by ten it's 550.
you'd need a nine sided die for the
expected value to be five dollars which
i'm not sure is geometrically possible
anyways i appreciate your attempt to
incorporate statistics into the show and
uh keep up the good work yeah i received
many corrections the expected value of
the imaginary ten-sided die
uh is five fifty not five the point i
was trying to make still remains but i
appreciate being corrected and i
appreciate the audience for keeping me
honest
but also accurate and it is an expected
value of 550 if you don't even know what
i'm talking about not a big deal uh we
have a great bonus show for you today
the ahmad arbory killing
with three
defendants in that trial
has moved beyond closing arguments and
is as we speak in prosecution rebuttal
and we're going to talk about how this
case differs from the kyle rittenhouse
case on today's bonus show we are also
going to talk about this bizarre
incident where a truck carrying cash
had some kind of an issue where the cash
ended up scattered all over a california
freeway and it caused quite a frenzy
we'll also talk about the difference
between a freeway and a highway i still
don't understand it maybe there isn't
one we will also talk about the covet
spike that's going on
in some parts of the united states
things are as bad right now
as they were last november why
and what is the outlook we're going to
talk about all of it on today's bonus
show you can sign up on my website
joinpakman.com become a member get
instant access to the bonus show we will
be here tomorrow with a new show and
then off the rest of the week for
thanksgiving but many programs still
coming up between now and then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two
all-form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allform.com
pacman